paroles et à monsieur philippe vitel
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je maintiendrais toute les
ressources affectées à la politique
familiale
souvenez vous monsieur le premier
ministre
c'était l'engagement numéro 16 du
candidat hollande à la présidentielle de
2012 malheureusement depuis se sont
succédé des mesures en totale
contradiction avec cette incantation
préélectorale je citerai par exemple le
double rabot du quotient familial
la réduction des aides à la garde
d'enfants la modulation des allocations
familiales la division par deux de la
prime à la naissance dans plus le
versement est décalée de deux mois c'est
au total 2,6 130 milliards d'euros qui
depuis 2013 ont été substitués aux 3,2
millions de familles injustement
victimes de votre politique
aussi ne sommes nous pas surpris collins
et qui a dévoilé mardi le bilan
démographique 2015 de la france nous
confirme une chute des naissances qui
passe de 2,1 96 enfants par femme
das la plus importante constatée depuis
20 ans nous députés du groupe l'est
républicain
ainsi bien sûr que les associations
familiales
nous avions pourtant alerté des
conséquences de vos mesures anti famille
sur la confiance des familles sur la
natalité
car même si le lien avec le taux de
fécondité n'est pas mécanique on ne peut
masquer les effets positifs des
politiques des dans la famille sur la
natalité
pour preuve lorsque le taux avait
dramatiquement chuté en 1994 c'est bien
une politique familiale volontariste
avec des mesures permettant de concilier
vie familiale et vie professionnelle qui
ont permis d'inverser la tendance en
redonnant confiance et stabilité aux
familles
monsieur le premier ministre la baisse
de notre natalité ne doit pas s'inscrire
dans la durée
quel message positif comptez-vous enfin
adressé aux familles de france merci la
parole est à madame laurence rossignol
secrétaire d'état chargée de la famille
l'enfance des personnes âgées et
l'autonomie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
philippe vitel la france continue d'être
le pays d'europe qui a le taux de
natalité le plus élevé et le taux de
fécondité le plus élevé et quand je dis
le plus élevé d'europe
nettement au dessus de bien nombreux nos
voisins nettement au dessus de l'épée
des pays qui nous ressemble pourtant
beaucoup
et donc cette politique familiale que
vous décriez est pourtant une politique
familiale offensive juste et équitable
d'abord parce qu'elle permet à la france
d'avoir toujours ce taux de natalité
extrêmement élevé et un taux d'activité
professionnelle des femmes que les
autres pays d'europe nous on nous envie
pourquoi parce que c'est d'abord dans
les modes d'accueil que la france
investit le budget des allocations
familiales consacrée au mode de garde
augmente et continue d'augmenter chaque
année 2 7%
nous n'avons pas renoncé à équiper
l'ensemble des communes territoires
ruraux comme territoire urbain de mode
d'accueil pour les enfants de moins de 3
ans comme nous avons développé l'accueil
des enfants à l'école des deux ans par
ailleurs la politique familiale que nous
conduisons est juste elle et
redistributive
elle est équitable nous avons fait le
choix de la réorienter en faveur des
familles les plus modestes et
particulièrement en faveur des familles
monoparentales qui sont
incontestablement celle qui souffre le
plus aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi nous
avons augmenté le complément familial
l'allocation de soutien familial
l'allocation rentrée scolaire et que
nous généralisons la garantie d un pays
de pension alimentaire pour les mères
dont les ex conjoint défaillant n'assure
pas l'éducation des enfants
ça c'est une politique familiale qui
produit des résultats et quant aux
extrapolations vous faites sur le lien
entre la politique familiale que nous
conduisons et la baisse de la natalité
aucun scientifique aucun démographe
aujourd'hui ne considère qu'il serait
juste et intelligente d'établir une
relation entre la baisse de la natalité
ponctuelles et la politique familiale
merci la parole est à mme hadad